I'm excited are you excited frames
frames frames frames frames frames
[Laughter]
frames frames frames okay we're back I
feel like this is all just market
recording you right it's like you hate
me it's like yay me
thank you or [ __ ] you I'm trying to help
you figure out which one trying to thank
[ __ ] me
I don't think thank you oh thanks [ __ ]
you look it's gotta be a PG thank
[ __ ] straight how do we restart the
how do we play I do it okay
oh wait does it oh okay well I hosted
the server
oh wait does it okay mark mark yes don't
walk like that's terrifying okay goodbye
wait I'm ready for you when your lover
and [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] you right all right
you right stop is that really mark oh I
was gonna go there you [ __ ] oh you
unbelievable what monster wait would do
great in medieval times by the way I
know you guys were concerned but the
frames are bad bad frames frames what
this is not fair
[Music]
watch this I'm getting my goddamn spot
back you see you can't hurt me but I'm
just saying we're four buddies right
buddy it's okay [ __ ] you thanks cuz
everybody watching followed Bob and wait
on their twitch channels yeah cuz if you
haven't [ __ ] you very good Plus forward
right it's really you are the recording
right you right you right you right you
right
[Laughter]
god I can't oh the one time my lid is
open I can't grab a [ __ ] grenade
before you [ __ ] he's got you in the
home what I'm gonna do mark I'm gonna
get this guy out because I'm gonna use
my other role to get away from that
you're teaming with ways now
just plain Oh No
you having fun it was good benefit good
dick I love good dick just mark to seven
or to work on post mates yes
no you lost your Pole oh we have to
restarted because you lose your ball
yeah it's the boat eight my pole I
didn't just drop it the boat I I think
I'm a fairness mark I think we should
restart I didn't drop my port
[Music]
[Applause]
here comes my reverse sorry I understand
you I see you you should have mortgaged
that Wade your advice is not really that
good I am you sure yeah no no okay
that's the last frames oh I hate you
[Laughter]
shut up
thank you so much I'd like to thank all
my fans you really brought me here thank
everyone for supporting me all these
years
crippling debt there's an app for that
cockfights doesn't happen for that poor
people poor people my controller is
still on and it's just vibrating my lap
for no reason alright mark owns a lot of
expensive property yeah I do yeah I do
baby
I do you
I just keep laughing because you guys
makes life so fun all right I think my
life is over
anybody want brick I've got a shitload
I've got a would like brick what do you
want for it
I want brick the door swings open she
walks in legs up to here something in
her eyes tells me she's looking for mark
how how much harder the cars do you have
very much why why would we want to
punish you why to win it's been a long
day you already won I can't wait to see
how this ends dude you you you know me I
know you and we know each other and you
know how this is gonna end
you done bro here whoa you don't like
the utilities not be fooled you are
kidding I'm kidding no monopolies out of
this body exactly four for two wouldn't
be fair for you in this exchange he
would have to give you all of his Marcus
over some jumping Oh body that's just
that's unnecessary I'm the funniest man
on the face of the earth will always get
you laid my sex dungeon agent that one's
for you so what's the big inside joke
just say asian sex dungeons in Asia
Asians that one's for you wait can you
make it just do it
wait it's fine I definitely won't kill
you again okay all right I'm gonna
believe you I choose to believe you all
right never mind go see mark
I told you you will this deal yeah
you win you right you right you right
you right you right you right right
thank you loving you is easy cuz your
socks what oh yeah well ok 9 I won't
it's about to go down
I've got what is our last time it is
going down no that's a road it is going
down this time 1 2 3 4 right 4 stone BAM
put those in there I get to wheat back
oh but wait they're not staying there
long cuz here's here's these then
there's this one and this one city going
in here
let's lap down here and bottom bing bada
boom but wait that's it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]